so I love making tools and sharing them
with people I remember as a child my
first tool I built was actually a
microscope that I built by stealing
lenses for my brother's eyeglasses
he was in that thrilled but you know
maybe because of that moment thirty
years later I'm still making microscopes
and the reason I built these tools is
for moments like this this is a
schooling barrier the living world far
supersedes our imagination of how things
actually work right oh my god I haven't
realized this would be such a universal
phrase over the last two years in my lab
we built 50,000 full scope and shipped
them 230 countries in the world at no
cost to the kids we sent them to this
year alone with the support of our
community we are planning to ship a
million microscopes to kids around the
world what does that do it creates an
inspiring community of people around the
world learning and teaching each other
from Kenya to Kampala to Kathmandu to
Kansas and one of the phenomenal things
that I love about this is the sense of
community there is a kid in Nicaragua
teaching others how to identify mosquito
species that carry dengue by looking at
the larvae under a microscope there's a
pharmacologist who came up with a new
way to detect fake drugs anywhere there
is a girl who wondered how does glitter
actually work and discovered the physics
of crystalline formation and glitter
there is an Argentinian doctor who's
trying to do field cervical cancer
screening with this tool and yours very
truly found a species of flea that was
dug inside my heel in my foot one
centimeter deep
now you might think of these as
anomalies but there is a method to this
madness
I call this frugal science the idea of
sharing experience of science and not
just the information remind you there
are billion people on this planet who
live it absolutely no infrastructure no
roads no electricity and thus no
healthcare also there are a billion kids
on this planet that live in poverty how
are we supposed to inspire them for the
next generation of solution makers there
are healthcare workers that we put on
the line to fight for infectious
diseases to protect us with absolutely
bare minimum tools and resources so as a
lab at Stanford I think of this from a
context of frugal science and building
solutions for these communities often we
think about being able to do diagnosis
under a tree off grid I'll tell you two
examples today of new tools one of them
starts in Uganda in 2013 on a field trip
to detect schistosomiasis with both
scopes I made a minor observation in a
clinic in a far remote area
I saw a centrifuge being used as a
doorstop I mean quite literally the
doorstop and I asked them and they said
oh we don't actually have electricity so
this piece of junk is as good as a
doorstop
you know centrifuges for some of you who
don't know are the pinnacle tool to be
able to do sample processing you
separate components of blood or body
fluids to be able to detect and identify
pathogens but centrifuges are bulky
expensive cost around $1,000 and really
hard to carry out in the field and of
course they don't work without power
sounds familiar
so we started thinking about solving
this problem and I came back kept
thinking about toys now I have a few
with me here I first started with yo-yos
and I am a terrible yo-yo thrower
because these objects spin we wondered
could be
actually use the physics of these
objects to be able to build centrifuges
this was possibly the worst throw I can
make but you might start realizing if
you start exploring the space space of
toys we tried these spinning tops and
then in the lab we stumbled upon this
wonder it's the whirligig or a buzzer or
a ruin a couple of strings and a little
disc and if I push it spins how many of
you have played with this as a kid this
is called a button on a string okay
maybe 50% of you what you didn't realize
that this little object is the oldest
toy in the history of mankind 5000 years
ago we have found relics of this object
hidden around on our planet now the
irony is we actually don't understand
how this little thing works that's when
I get excited so we got back to work
wrote down a couple of equations if you
take the input torque that you put in
you take the drag on this disk and the
twist drag on these strings you should
be able to mathematically solve this
this is not the only equation in my talk
10 pages of math later we can actually
write down the complete analytical
solution for this dynamic system and
outcomes what we call paper fuge that's
my postdoc saad bangla who's the
co-inventor of paper fusion to the left
you see all the centrifuges that we're
trying to replace this little object
that you see right here is a disc a
couple of strings and a handle and when
I spin and I push it starts to spin now
when you realize when you do the mat
when we calculate the RPM for this
object mathematically we should be able
to go all the way to a million rpm now
there is a little twist in human anatomy
because the resonant frequency of this
object is around 10 Hertz and if you
ever played piano you can't go higher
than 2 or 3 Hertz the maximum speed
we've been able to achieve with this
object is not 10,000 rpm not 50,000 rpm
then 20,000 rpm that's equal into 30,000
g-forces if I was to stick you right
here and have it spin you would think
about the types of forces you would
experience one of the factors of a tool
like this is to be able to do diagnosis
with this so I'm going to do a quick
demo here where so this is a moment
where I'm going to make a little
fingerprint tiny drop of blood is going
to come out if you don't like blood you
don't have to look at it here is a
little Lancet these lancets are
available everywhere completely passive
and if I've had breakfast today that
didn't hurt at all okay I take a little
capillary with a drop of blood
now this drop of blood has answers
that's why I'm interested in it it might
actually tell me whether I have malaria
right now or not I take a little
capillary and you see it starts leaking
in I'm going to draw a little more blood
and that's good enough for right now now
I just seal this capillary by putting it
in clay and now let's feel this sample
we're going to take the sample mount it
on paper fuge
a little piece of tape to make a sealed
cavity so now the sample is completely
enclosed and we are ready for a spin I
am pushing and pulling with this object
I'm going to load this up and you see
the object starts spinning unlike a
regular centrifuge this is a counter
rotating centrifuge it goes back and
forth back and forth and now I'm
charging it up and you see it builds
momentum and now I don't know if you can
hear this thirty seconds of this and I
should be able to separate all the blood
cells with the plasma and the ratio of
those blood cells to posner already if
you see right here if you focus on this
you should be able to see a separated
volume of blood and plasma and the ratio
of that actually tells me whether I
might be anemic one of the aspects of
this is we build many types of paper
fuses this one allows us to identify
malaria parasites by running them for a
little longer and we can identify
malaria parasites that are in the blood
that we can separate out and detect with
something like a centrifuge another
version of this allows me to separate
nucleic acids to be able to do nucleic
acid tests out in the field itself here
is another version that allows me to
separate bulk samples and then finally
something new that we've been working on
to be able to implement the entire
multiplex test on an object like this so
where you do the sample preparation and
the chemistry in the same object now
this is all good but when you start
thinking about this you have to share
these tools with people and one of the
things that we did is we just got back
from Madagascar this is what political
trials for malaria looks like you can do
this while having coffee but most
importantly this is a village six hours
from any road
now we are in a room with one of the
senior members of the community and a
healthcare worker and it really is this
portion of the work that really excites
me the most that smile to be able to
share simple but powerful tools with
people around the world now I forgot to
tell you this that all of that cost me
20 cents to make okay in the negative
time I have left I'll tell you about the
most recent invention from our lab it's
called a buzz the idea that all of you
could help us fight mosquitoes you could
all help us track our enemies these are
enemies because they cause malaria zika
chikungunya dengue but the challenge is
that we actually don't know where our
enemies are the world map for where
mosquitoes are are missing so we started
thinking about this there are 3,500
species of mosquitoes and they're all
very similar some of them are so
identical that even an entomologist
cannot identify them under a microscope
but they have an Achilles heel this is
what a mosquito flirting with each other
looks like that's a male chasing a
female they're actually talking to each
other with their rings each frequency
and thus they have a signet ring we
realized that using a regular phone a
five to ten dollar flip phone how many
remember what this object is we can
record these acoustic signatures from
mosquitoes and I'll tell you exactly how
to do this
I caught the mosquitoes outside unlike
Bill I'm not going to release them but I
will tell you how to record from this
all you do is you tap them and they fly
you can first test I can actually hear
that and you bring your phone which has
microphones it turns out the mics are so
damn good already
even on regular phones but you can pick
up this near-field signature and since
I'm out of time let me just play the
recording that I made a day ago
this is all the charming sound that you
heard before that you all love okay one
of the context of this is being able to
do this with a regular cell phone allows
us to map mosquito species using a flip
phone we mapped one of the largest
acoustic database with 25 to 20 species
of mosquitoes that carry human pathogens
and from this in machine learning
anybody who uploads this data we can
identify until the probability of what
species of mosquitoes you're actually
working with we call this a bus and if
any of you want to sign up just go to
the website let me close with something
that's very important and dear to my
heart one of the challenges of today is
we have terrible problems we have a
billion people with absolutely no health
care climate change biodiversity loss on
and on and on and we hope that science
is going to provide the answer but
before you leave this theater today I
want you to promise one thing we're
going to make finds accessible not just
to the people who can afford it but a
billion others who can't
let's make science and scientific
literacy a human right the moment that
you pass the tingling feeling of making
a discovery to another child you're
enabling them to be the next group of
people who will actually solve these
problems thank
[Applause]